[Music]
for 60 years including 48 and Counting
right here at CBS News Bob Schieffer has
been asking questions of Presidents and
newsmakers to help us understand the
world and he's not done reporting yet
the CBS News political contributor has
has a new book out called overload
finding the truth and today's deluge of
news and it examines how changes in the
media are affecting not only how but
what we consume as news Bob good morning
we need this book now more than ever but
first let's talk about some of the news
the Secretary of State Rex Tillerson in
an extraordinary press conference having
to come out to deny that he's disloyal
to the president although he didn't deny
that he called the president a [ __ ]
well you know extraordinary is certainly
the word I can never remember a
Secretary of State calling a news
conference to say he's loyal to the
President and then going into the rest
of it I I think it's gonna be very
difficult for this Secretary of State to
continue in his job because it's widely
known in Washington that the president
has simply lost confidence in him and
and when that kind of word gets around
it's very hard to get get your job done
I think he's a patriot and all of that
but you know this I just don't see how
this goes on I mean when he's going out
talking about trying to make contact
with North Korea and the president cuts
his legs off in public and says don't
fool with that so do you think it's
never succeed made it worse yesterday or
do you think that it helped the
situation I don't see how it helped but
I mean this was not like a news
conference it was more like a hostage
tape it seemed to me
I mean how so well I mean why was he
there you know I mean the Washington
Post this morning they quote night there
say they have checked with 19 sources I
mean this that's the new record for a
number of sources that say he's a
short-timer and you know the word is
he'll be gone by Christmas so I don't
know what happens but I don't see how
this helped much of anything well not
only that his Secretary of Defense is
testifying before Carter saying that I
said
port the iran-contra I mean the Iran
American nuclear deal and the president
said I haven't decide to side it but I'm
not gonna tell you what I think you know
I used to say that my favorite beat was
was Capitol Hill because up there
everybody's an independent contractor
that's how you get news I used to say
the difference between that and the
White House is it the White House
everybody works for the same person
yeah well that's no longer apt because
you can get as many different points of
view and there is many different
factions in the White House now as there
are up on Capitol Hill that's not the
book that's the timing of your book is
so perfect because you talk about fake
news in the book just yesterday Donald
Trump said fake news fake news talking
about NBC in the report about the [ __ ]
comment but you know as you point out
this is not new acrimony between the
press and the president so not not in
the least and I mean you know I was
there when Spiro Agnew called us Natalie
bomb hey Bob negativity I mean we've
been called name written by for builds
that part yeah yeah and I think Pat
Buchanan had a hand in that but people
are getting their news from to now for
many different what is the difference
yes we're so overloaded from information
with so many different sources that it's
hard to separate the weak from the chaff
so we better off because we have so much
more information today
right now we're simply overwhelmed by it
because we're in the midst of this
communications revolution that is
totally changed not only how we get the
news but our whole culture and what's
the danger to the Republic well the
danger is that once this stuff gets out
there it's so hard to knock it down and
and we're seeing that every day look at
the day after the shooting out in Las
Vegas
there were stories on the internet that
the he was a recent convert to to Islam
that he was connected in some way with
Isis that he was a big fan of Rachel
Maddow is if that's some sort of a sin
well all of that was totally false but I
mean it even fooled me I mean I saw this
thing about he'd recently converted to
Islam and I called CBS this morning one
of the producers and said is that right
and she said no there's some people we
think they'll Bob more News better
informed well the good news about social
media now is that just like David Bengal
was talking about how neighbors down
there in Puerto Rico we're connecting
with each other how they were emailing
him and texting him and he was able to
get help but the other part is the stuff
that appears on social media does not go
through the same vetting process that
people used to know about and we used to
trust when we had three television
stations in every 10 star that as a
newsman you started as a newspaper man
and yuba moan the loss of newspapers and
also you Ramon the fact that people in
between the two coasts don't have
newspapers and there's no there's no
corrective to power in so many
communities in 2004 one reporter in
eight lived in New York Washington or
Los Angeles that number is now down to
one in five if live in one of those
three cities so in many parts of the
country now we've lost 126 newspapers
over the last 12 years in many parts of
the country it's not a question of
getting biased news or that it's a
question of getting no news and and
they're getting 67% of us now get at
least some of our news on Facebook again
there are great advantages there but it
is not vetted in the way that the news
we used to get from newspapers and from
the mainstream media presented it
alright Bob Schieffer always good to see
you in person and have you here at the
table thank you thank you appreciate it
overload it's on sale now wherever you
like to buy your books